peut se tutoyer mais cela donne
déjà la directive dans un style le rôle
d'une personne directive dans la
nouvelle série doute raisonnable on est
en plein dans l'actualité parce que
c'est une policière qui travaillent au
sein de l'escouade d'investigation sur
les crimes à caractère sexuel
est ce que c'est un problème pour toi ça
maintenant le problème monde entier oui
vous incarnez aussi une policière dans
19 2 l'ex de bérat oui ça aboutit à
quand les rôles de policier mais en fait
la vérité c'est que c'est drôle parce
que d'innover moi ça fait quand même
assez longtemps ça que j'étais très
heureuse de renouer avec la police parce
que parce que c'est vraiment il ya
quelque chose de très excitant à jouer
ce genre de personnage le parce qu'ils
ont des professions strict avec des
notions strict des façons de faire
leur mode leur modus operandi leur façon
d'agir leur protocole ça devient un peu
leur mode de fonctionnement c'est super
intéressant en agression sexuelle si
traumatique
aurait violé des femmes parce que j'suis
pas le cas pour moi savoir dans sa vie
dans ce cas-ci de doute raisonnable
là c'est sûr que
j'avais à fréquenter un personnage
beaucoup plus empathique en tout cas
c'est comme ça que je les aborder puis
c'est tellement pour moi ces deux
personnages tellement différent le
isabelle la tendresse dans dix-neuf de l
avait été vraisemblablement très grande
intelligence et crédibilité mais en
coeur de pierre
d'ailleurs c'est la police qu'il
la mère elle arrive qu'à à ce que notre
émission que tu avais comme l'impression
que ça a changé la vie des gens qui
reçoivent témoignages vraiment émouvant
mais dans lequel je voudrais qu'on
m'efface oui il ya quelqu'un qui m'a
envoyé un témoignage aux enquêtes
sa mère c'était mon personnage du dépôt
du jury
fini les couilles le logo logique qu'un
civil budget de blé avant même envoyé la
photo de sa maman qui a à me confier
tepa rouages tout ce qu'elle avait
traversé les enfants billets qui
commencent leur vie qu'ils sont
hypothétiques qui ont pas tous les
outils pour la traversée mois de toutes
les cadres du monde c'est celle qui
touche le plus c'est bien il faut y
penser que notre image programmée
aujourd'hui
moi j'ai découvert dans minuit le soir
c'est vrai que j'ai aimé aussi beaucoup
et jouer une femme forte et entre que ce
genre de requêtes reçues dans toute ta
carrière comment tu expliques sion mais
c'est pas la règle et ce avec pauvres
parce que moi quand je sortis du
conservatoire
c'est une actrice très candide
beaucoup en légèreté t on
de même que j'avais un peu l'énergie de
marie soleil tougas j'avais quelque
chose de très vivant qui spontanée puis
tout écraser sur les îles mort tout
écraser la spontanéité c'est lui qui m'a
façon le pire je savais pourquoi je sais
pas par où commencer puis je me trouvais
pas prête toujours j'avais une belle
personnalité mais chut on n'aurait
jamais dit moi que jeune fille avec
beaucoup de caractère c'était pas une
idée mais caractéristique qui maintenant
mais je trouve que c'est une sur
spéciale ne soit pas au web parce que ça
devient une source spatiale baisse parce
que j'allais tellement défendu ce
tableau s'est rendue facile facile
maintenant même l'autorité dans d'autres
raisonnable je n'ai jamais poussé parce
que parce qu'il ya quelque chose qui
devient un peu mais ça commençait
vraiment avec minutes soit mais c'était
pas c'était pas mon casting minus
n'était pas du tout mes habiletés
principal ces deux étrangers c'est
monsieur ponza madame frôla qui arrive
dans la ville va parler du conservatoire
où il ya la julie perreault qui a fait
beaucoup de théâtre au début de sa
carrière en tout - aujourd'hui pourquoi
les enfants les enfants c'est vraiment
un choix parce que avoir des tout-petits
puis partir pendant 1 mois nié tous les
soirs j'avais le coeur brisé j'avais
réellement le cab répit puis j'ai
commencé aussi à avoir plus écoute quand
j'ai eu thomas j'ai eu à 24 heures tout
de suite on m'a aussi proposé mes
projets premier projet télé avec postes
dans trois fois rien et tout ce qui est
assez additionner très rapidement j'ai
trouvé mon espace de création avec les
familles de télé de cinéma qui le
théâtre j'ai dû y renoncer souvent parce
que j'avais des choix à faire les
enfants sont grands ouais parce que
l'auteur est revenue certainement j'ai
même jeu se manifester derniers mois que
j'aimerais beaucoup retourner sur les
planches du café je suis prête à à à
délaisser un peu le lit pas naturel pour
aller jouer quelque chose de plus grand
que soi qu'il faut le faire parce que
parce que parce qu'on peut se jouer
soi-même constamment lotis maintenant ça
passe beaucoup trop vite bah non après
morts non non non mais qui s'attendent
pas à ce que j'avais plein récent satan
et j'attends vieilli mort dans merci
pour tout il ya une complicité tannante
avec magalie lépine blondeau est ce
qu'encore aujourd'hui vous échanger sur
le métier de comédien je pense que c'est
ma plus grande complice de discussion
sur notre travail et à l'univers mais
c'est vraiment mon premier répondant
caen table tout même aux questionnements
sur le mexique n'est pas quelqu'un qui
porte bagages de questionnements puis de
lourdes à mon métier je l'adorent sauf
que des fois bien ce déblocage d'un team
plus tu dis pas que c'est sûr que c'est
plus facile d'en parler à une amie qui
va gagner
on a souvent ce genre de conversation la
jud 0 merci beaucoup merci est ce que tu
es sûr hors de tout doute que c'est le
but inviolé
qui